madame monsieur bonjour et bienvenue sur
le plateau de la voie est libre en
bourgogne à quelques jours de l'examen à
l'assemblée nationale de la réforme
constitutionnelle
nous allons évoquer les deux articles du
projet après les attentats de novembre
ces articles concernent l'inscription
dans la constitution de l'état d'urgence
et la déchéance de nationalité pour les
personnes condamnées pour acte de
terrorisme alors pour en discuter sont
réunis sur ce plateau car abou zian
bonjour vous êtes député socialiste de
la 3e circonscription de côte-d'or
jean-baptiste lemoyne en face de vous
bonjour vous êtes sénateur les
républicains de l'yonne et probablement
parce que vous êtes le seul candidat
futur président du parti dans le
département
paul garrigues bonjour je vous ai de la
ligue des droits de l'homme que vous
représentez ici et frédéric paillard
bonjour jeune secrétaire régional
d'alliance police nationale pour la
région bourgogne franche comté alors
avant de parler du fond de la réforme à
mot sur sa première conséquence la
démission de la ministre de la justice
c'était mercredi dernier
opposé à la déchéance de nationalité
christiane taubira a évoqué un désaccord
politique majeur elle est remplacée par
le député du finistère jean jacques
urvoas approche du premier ministre
manuel valls car vous êtes vous
regretter ce départ de christiane
taubira qui était quand même la figure
emblématique de la gauche dans ce
gouvernement oui je le regrette
au-delà du fait qu'elle était la figure
je regrette la femme qu'elle la ministre
quelle a été sa qu'on sait qu'on pète
ans son talent oratoire mais aussi sa
force de conviction
c'est là qu'elle est partie d'ailleurs
tout à fait est-ce que du coup la
majorité se rétrécit encore un peu plus
écoutez j'ai pas mesurer ou verra bien
et est ce que ça vous paraît logique
quand même 7 ce départ pour la cohérence
gouvernementale comme kadir le porte
parole du gouvernement
je pense que quand on n'est pas d'accord
effectivement avec la ligne du
gouvernement
le mieux et c'est ce qu'elle a fait
c'est
c'est de ne plus en faire partie elle a
pris ses responsabilités c'est une
c'est une décision qui n'est pas facile
à prendre
elle l'a pris avec courage et dignité
jean-baptiste lemoyne la droite perd sa
cible privilégiée finalement là bas
écouter fin du feuilleton de façon
provisoire très avec ont quand même
considérablement contribué à alimenter
ce feuilleton tout au long du mois de
décembre et affecté près le ton sur et
bien sûr les mesures qu'avait annoncé le
président de la république et qui était
refusé par une partie de cette majorité
ils sont même de son gouvernement ce qui
était quand même assez hallucinant
maintenant nous ce qu'on attend surtout
c'est qu'il soit mis fin à cette
politique de désarmement pénale qu'elle
a conduite quand même avec cette fois en
2014 et puis elle a fait des choses dans
les cartons aussi qui pardon mais voilà
passé palais dans le bon sens donc
maintenant on attend de voir sur les
actes un monsieur revoir vous êtes
d'accord avec votre collègue de l'yonne
guillaume larrivé qui disait qu'elle a
été la pierre ministre de la république
en tout cas je suis d'accord et puis
pour dire que l a contribué vraiment à
prendre des mesures pénales qui à mon
avis n'allez pas dans le bon sens et de
ce point de vue là voilà je pense que le
le nouveau a du pain sur la planche et
on est prêt à contribuer aussi paul
garrigues la ligue des droits de l'homme
alors s'opposer à ce projet
constitutionnel en organisant notamment
aujourd'hui une série de manifestations
dans tout le pays
quel regard vous portez sur la démission
de la ministre de la justice agit en
tant que social ou encore d'un point de
vue personnel
on pourrait dire quelque part ça rassure
de dire qu'il y a des gens en haut
niveau de s'inviter qui font passer
leurs convictions leur carrière après
son prendre un point de vue plus
politique qu'on peut que trouve
inquiétant c'est qu'on a eu deux
personnes dans ces gouvernements qui
sont démarqués sur la question de la
défense des droits de l'homme
cécile duflot par rapport aux propos
xénophobes
en tout cas nous les haïssent comme tel
tenus par monsieur val sur les robes et
madame taubira sur cette question et qe2
on est obligé de partir et ça ça nous
semble inquiétant à ce qui nous semble
que c'est important que des gens qui
défendent et qui a un poids sur des
vigilance sur les questions de liberté
droits de l'homme
elle ne pouvait plus le faire de
l'intérieur visiblement il faut le
croire
frédéric paillard est ce que vous êtes
satisfait vous du départ de madame
taubira on sait que votre syndicat
n'était pas vraiment sur la même ligne
digne hôtel je pense que les syndics des
syndicats représentant les policiers
quel qu'il soit un avis qui est quand
même assez particulier puisque cette
ministre l'a quand même pris quelques
mesures qui ont complexifié d'une part
la procédure pénale les collègues sur le
terrain demande un allègement de la
procédure demande à ce que le droit des
victimes soit respectée et demande
surtout à pouvoir travailler en sécurité
donc sous malheureusement sous l'ère de
madame taubira qui est il faut le noter
quand même une femme de caractère et de
conviction le geste fait pour les
serviteurs de l'état et les auxiliaires
de justice que sous les policiers n'a
pas été celui qu'attendaient nos
collègues sur le terrain et du coup vous
êtes satisfait que ce soit jean jacques
urvoas spécialisé questions de sécurité
dit-on qui la remplace écoutez nous on
attend plutôt qu'un remplacement ce
qu'on attend on attend un changement
puisque on veut vraiment des signes
forts le président de la république
après les événements et notamment au
mois d'octobre alors que la pole à la
grogne policière se faisait sentir a
pris des engagements
donc maintenant la balle est dans le
camp du gouvernement et du ministre pour
que ces engagements soient tenus et que
les policiers gendarmes et personnes
chargées d'assurer la sécurité et la
justice en france puissent travailler on
va dire dans des conditions qui soient
acceptables et que effectivement la
justice puisse passer je réfute un peu
les arguments qui viennent d'être d'être
avancés on lui a toujours fait ce procès
de laxisme et quand vous analysez les
chiffres ce n'est pas le cas et je crois
que ce n'est pas l'émission pour en
faire le bilan de la faire le bilan de
madame taubira mais ça n'est pas vrai ça
n'est pas vrai et en termes de moyens
alors peut-être que la police et ça je
suis d'accord avec vous les moyens de la
police sont encore insuffisants mais en
mai il faut savoir d'où l'on revient
quand on sait quand même que
il ya eu j'aime pas trop accabler la
majorité d'avant mais il ya eu quand
même des pertes de moyens dans la police
dans la gendarmerie qu'on essaye de
rattraper
vous avez raison tout à l'heure vous
avez évoqué le fait que c'est lent pour
remonter la pente mais ça n'est pas du
fait de madame taubira
ça a été la ministre qui a obtenu le
plus de moyens en terme de magistrats en
termine dans la pénitentiaire et les
directeurs de prisons aujourd'hui la
justice a augmenté la pièce accord il a
augmenté
relativisons aujourd'hui aujourd'hui il
a augmenté de 4 ans augmenter d'un
milliard cinq pour mille de la culture
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui le directeur de dépôt des
des centres pénitentiaires lui rendent
hommage et et reconnaissent toutes les
avancées qu'elle a pu apporter
alors vas pas faire donc le bilan du
ministère de la justice où madame
taubira
en tout cas la démissionner car il était
donc opposé au principe de la déchéance
de nationalité pour les personnes
condamnées pour acte de terrorisme on va
dire ça comme ça il faut que le
gouvernement trouve une solution pour
que cette réforme soit adoptée aux trois
cinquièmes des sénateurs et des députés
qui seront donc prochainement réunis en
congrès à versailles comme ça a été le
cas d'ailleurs au lendemain des
attentats du mois de novembre
le texte a été remanié cette semaine la
commission des lois à l'assemblée
nationale a adopté jeudi
il n'y a plus de référence à la
binationalité on avait beaucoup fait
débat sur ce sujet là est-ce que du coup
ça vous convient
madame boutin alors la déchéance de la
nationalité elle
l'objectif de ce texte c'est quoi c'est
de lutter contre le terrorisme
est ce que cette proposition va faire en
sorte que l'on ait moins d'actes
terroristes sur notre territoire
moi je ne suis pas persuadé parce que
quand vous voyez que ce qu'il commette
les actes sont prêts à se faire sauter
eux mêmes ils sont prêts à mourir
ah non je n'aime pas dire mourir au
combat dans ce cas n'est pas un combat
ici ils s'attaquent à des gens qui sont
pas armés et donc à quelle est l'utilité
de cette déchéance maintenant que le
fait de ne plus précise et pour les
binationaux
ça n'exclut en rien que ça les
concernera de grandir au premier chef
de toute façon puisque quand ils seront
pas binationaux on peut pas les rendre
apatride
mais quand ils seront binationaux on
leur enlève la nationalité française
donc ils deviennent étrangers et donc
dense à royan mais ça revient exactement
même des français qui étaient français
qui doivent être français à part entière
vont à un certain moment être
différencié des autres français et ça je
ne l'admets pas monsieur le voile est
scanné cible puis vous dire si ce n'est
que en fait depuis l'annnonce fait par
présente la république au congrès en
réalité on assiste à monsieur bricolage
françois hollande c'est monsieur
bricolage chaque semaine a apporté son
lot de déclarations des uns de
positionnement des autres et par
conséquent de tentatives de rafistolage
pour essayer d'obtenir une majorité au
sein de sa majorité et une majorité tout
court et du coup c'était une demande d
appâter du coup de m'excuser racontez
nous sur la déchéance de nationalité on
a en a aucun sujet de principe mais ce
qu'on a vu c'est que le président
lorsqu'il a mis ça sur le tapis lors du
congrès il pensait faire un coup il
pensait prendre la droite au piège pour
l'obliger à voter est en fait le piège
on se rend compte qu'ils se retournent
contre la gauche qui s'est retrouvée
totalement divisée sur ce sujet et donc
moi j'ai envie de dire y compris là dans
la nouvelle rédaction c'est très très
malin très florentin parce qu'ils
essayent le groupe de consigner tout le
monde
isaiah la faute co2 obtenir les trois
cinquièmes de récupérer une partie de sa
majorité en enlevant la référence aux
binationaux dans le texte même de la
constitution mais en réalité vous avez
raison madame ça s'appliquera à eux
prioritairement dans la loi ordinaire
est ce qu'il faut pour y aura pas
d'arrivée à patrick racialement on donne
on donne des arguments aux frondeurs
pour se rallier
mais ce qui est dommage c'est que c'est
au détriment du fond parce que quand on
lit le texte précisément alors c'est du
droit mais cette déchéance de
nationalité dans la nouvelle version
soumise par le gouvernement eh bien on
précis c'est lorsqu'une personne a
commis un acte terroriste
ça veut dire qu'en réalité on restreint
la loi existante
aujourd'hui la loi ordinaire existant
sur des chansons nationalité est plus
large que ça et donc voilà pour
facialement donner des arguments à sa
majorité le gouvernement est en train de
rétrécir le champ de ses
l'échéance bon voila tu avales élargir à
ceux qui commettent des délits aussi à
certains délits certains délits alors un
certain d on ne sait encore pas
lesquelles
céline est plus grave a dit le système
fermé reprendre monsieur le moigne
j'aimerais que vous évitez d'utiliser le
nom le mot de fronde
nous sommes des parlementaires avant
d'être frondeurs alors si des
parlementaires doivent être muselés à
quoi ça sert d'aller siéger non mais
vous je suis le premier très indépendant
vous savez je le fais les parlementaires
socialistes se sont autoproclamés eux
mêmes non moi je voi étiqueté de france
2 mais alors on devrait tous se réjouir
les sénateurs et les députés que canada
qu'on ait un débat et qu'on ne
représente que ceux qui nous ont élus
c'est à dire le ford et on l'a on parle
on est après le 13 on après le 13
novembre
au-delà du débat sur ce qu'on attend
c'est de l'action c'était mon erreur des
mesures si justement mais c'est démesuré
aux crêtes enfin je parle sous contrôle
on est d'accord de mon voisin il ya
besoin d'outils a besoin en les
déperditions il ya besoin d'adapter la
loi et pas la mi juin pour un certain
nombre d'actions à la police c'est via
l'état d'urgence on va en parler dans un
assange aurait confiné sur la déchéance
pour le garric vous votre regard
j'imagine que vous êtes opposé nesko
pour le symbole est ce que finalement
est-ce que c'est révoltant d'enlever la
nationalité un français qui finalement
s'attaque à la france et à ses valeurs
si nous les preuves comme tout le monde
le dit elle même ce qu'ils défendent se
sert à rien après c'est un symbole et un
symbole qui nous choque vraiment c'est
que ça met alors en prenant par rapport
à des crimes parmi les plus horribles et
à partir de l'indignation légitime de la
population
on met le doigt quand même dans la
remise en cause de principes
fondamentaux c'est que tout citoyen quel
que soit le crime qu'il a connu tous les
citoyens doivent être jugés de la même
façon et sanctionnés s'ils ont commis
des crimes de la même façon c'est le
principe lors c'est le principe
d'égalité devant tous les citoyens de
brins de tous les siennes dans la loi
qu'écornée et ça quand on met le doigt
de temps c'est toujours
re tout ça sert à rien vous avez dit et
deuxième chose aussi nous qui nous a
beaucoup choqués c'est quand même
stigmatiser une partie de la population
s'est laissé entendre qu'une partie des
citoyens de ce pays en général parce que
leurs parents sont nés ailleurs parce
que c'est le cas de la plupart des
binationaux enfin quoique y en a aussi
d'autres pour d'autres raisons 1
mais qu'une partie des citoyens seraient
à considérer autrement serait plus
dangereux je peux rien de trouvent les
criminels qui ont été retrouvés dans ces
affaires n'étaient pas des binationaux
mais on s'est quand même mettre le doigt
mais n'est pas du goût des nationaux pas
forcément français mais belgo marocain
c'est quand même eux pointé du doigt une
partie de la population et c'est
particulièrement dangereux parce
qu'aujourd'hui nous disons que cela bien
la dernière chose à faire aujourd'hui
pour lutter contre le terrorisme
c'est de stigmatiser une partie de la
population stigmatisée ceux qui sont à
l'origine ou tel retrait que ce qui
l'est c'est en tout ce qu'il ne faut pas
faire si on veut dire il faut unir
l'ensemble de la population sur des
valeurs démocratiques et c'est pour ça
que ce sac surtout qui nous semble
dangereux le message qu'avait derrière
certains nationaux dont certains sont
très connus sont des ministres je pense
notamment à la ministre de l'éducation
nationale qui disait elle ne pas se
sentir visés puisque ça ne visait que
des terreurs est sûre vous pouvez tirer
et c'est vrai que je me sens pas
concerné seulement je ne veux pas que et
ça fait un reportage sur le terrain vous
verrez comment les les binationaux le
vivent même s'ils n'ont rien à se
reprocher et on parvint à près de l'état
d'urgence et on verra même parlé tout à
l'heure de l'utilité c'est vrai que
est-ce que vous pour vous pour votre
syndicat ça peut avoir une utilité
cette déchéance de nationalité on voit
effectivement que la plupart des
théories semeur eux-mêmes dans leurs
attentats c'est un outil donc il va
falloir évaluer la pertinence et la
réalité d'applications sur le terrain
parce que je pense que c'est encore
quelque chose qui va être très difficile
à mettre en oeuvre et c'est quelque
chose qui dans l'application de ce qui
va en effet va revenir d'une part à la
justice où on a déjà des gens
travaillent déjà dans des conditions
même la députée l'a dit tout à l'heure
sont quand même un peu extrême et nos
collègues sur le terrain qu'ils sont
censés faire appliquer les décisions de
justice et faire respecter les lois vont
se trouver dans quelque chose qui va
être très compliqué pour eux puisque la
c 'est c'est quelque chose qui touche
quand même à des symboles et c'est
vraiment très particulier de manipuler
genre d'outil donc après évaluer la
pertinence s'il est mis en place
on ne pourra le faire que quand le cac
se présentera réellement après quelque
part on peut penser que si la décision
est prise et si éventuellement elle
venait à être mise en oeuvre
c'est peut-être une chose qui peut
permettre d'éviter ce qu'on a connus au
nom de l'eau tout au long de l'année
2015 25 ans au plus tôt quand même des
criminels en prison
on a beaucoup de choses on a beaucoup de
choses qui sont à évaluer sur le temps
puisque je vous rappelle quand même
qu'il existe encore des commissions des
platanes et des choses comme ça dans nos
institutions
donc forcément sur des problèmes comme
ça je pense qu'on va on va quand même
attendre un moment oui avant de juger de
la pertinence de la chose non mais ça
veut dire qu'on va on va aujourd'hui
arrêter quelqu'un qui va être jugé qu'il
va être condamné à 20 ans 25 ans de
prison et si elle a sorti de ses 25 ans
de prison qui sera déchu de l'année put
madame le député une simple question
pensez-vous 20 à 25 ans de prison et
penser qu'une personne qui a tué 140 ou
150 personnes sortent au bout de 25 ans
la remettre dans la rue en liberté c'est
un peu manga ça est ce que vous pensez
de madame qu' on en est déjà à ce niveau
là cn c'est un autre problème
alors pour le moment ils se font sauter
la tête de toute façon on les retrouve
en niait pas tous nous sommes pas tous
très justement alors la rentrée
compressé
là cela ça revient aux vrais sujets
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour éviter ça rit
curité la sécurité et les moyens à
donner
et là je vous rejoins mais c'est pas la
déchéance de la nationalité qui va les
dissuader la première des choses
d'ailleurs quand on les voit sur
certaines vidéos sur sur les sur les
écrans la première des choses qu'il faut
justement enfin ça va jusque là ils
brûlent leur passeport français
alors vous savez ça va partir du moment
où ils ont déjà fait le geste
à partir du moment où ils ont déjà fait
le geste de brûler leur passeport c'est
ce que j'allais vous dire que le geste
ait brûlé le passeport et de brûler le
drapeau français je pense que c'est des
symboles quand même c'est que cette
nation l'un sexe et cette nationalité ne
leur convient pas une leur l'influencera
il peut faire ce pour me relaxer et
terroristes effectivement souvent en
prennent des cibles symboliques
on l'a vu avec charlie on l'a vu en
s'attaquant à des lieux de vie donc
effectivement même si ce n'est qu'un
symbole eh bien je pense que le symbole
eh bien il doit être assumée et jeudi
alors que ces voix là c'est une
proposition qui fait à la prison la
république
donc moi j'ai aucun état d'âme pour
voter symbole parce que symbole contre
ce symbole ya un moment où il fallait
quand il faut il faut qu'on montre que
ben voilà on redresse la tête
on laisse pas faire et que celui qui
s'excluent lui-même eh bien on l'exclût
nous vous validez l'idée que un symbole
qui va diviser et touchant aux droits
civiques vous mettrait d'accord
symbole pour symbole on s'intéresse à
l'histoire à la libération pour un
certain nombre de collaborateurs et une
défense des droits civiques
mais à l'époque on a pas dit on des
choix des droits civiques
selon l'origine les gens quoi les ont
été déchus des droits civiques par
rapport aux crimes commis
sap est question dire ça peut exister et
si on dirait qu'il peut y avoir une
peine pour l'essentiel c'est que les
gens soient arrêtés nir hors d'état de
commettre de crime est sanctionné pour
ce qu'ils ont fait ce qui à l'issue de
tout ça et gouailleur une défense des
droits civiques
c'est quelque chose qui peut avoir un
sens joly qui a été fait contre les
collaborateurs la libération mais qui
aurait un sens de dire ça a été évoqué
cette semaine tout crime identique à une
sanction identique et nous ça nous
semble essentiel parce que c'est un
principe
fondamentales de la république pourrait
l'entendre on pouvait l'entendre
si ce n'avait pas été annoncée
officiellement par un président de
république en congrès au lendemain des
attaques parce qu'en réalité tout recul
est une capitulation symbolique aussi et
c'est pour ça que même si conscient des
limites de ce dispositif
moi je retrait est justement justement
tout recul elle le fait que diddy
pèlerins qui remettent en cause qu'ils
nous font aller jusqu'à modifier la
constitution sait déjà c'est déjà un
gain pour eux c'est déjà une quelque
chose à mettre à leur profit et ça c'est
quand même lamentable et jeux pour vous
rejoindre
le problème c'est que cette décision
elle a été prise sur le feu à la va vite
à la va vite pour les jours d'autres
ajouts ap le but sans le vouloir au
morne ayant fait en un cas le sens de
nos morts n'étaient pas secs et est ce
que c'est c'est c'est pas mieux
d'attendre et de prendre du recul avant
de prendre des décisions
assemat c'est ma conception des choses
techniquement par contre on est bien
d'accord que ça peut être une peine
complémentaire puisque la déchéance de
droits civils civiques et de famille
s'applique dans le droit commun que ça
soit appliquée ou non aux cas de
terrorisme n'est pas quelque chose qui
soit totalement totalement fantasque est
totalement démesurée puisque les
tribunaux society et c'est eux qui
décideront
donc après ça sera à la justice ça sera
au garde des sceaux de l'époque de
prendre les mesures et de faire ce qu il
en voudra c'est un peu quelque part
c'est un peu un code de bonne conduite
et 6 est appliquée et que c'est efficace
on saluera éventuellement le courage de
certains de l'avoir fait et si c'est pas
appliquée que c'est pas efficace et bien
on en tirera les conséquences qu'il
faudra alors on a longtemps à la
prévention plutôt a fait céder à l'état
d'urgence qui est censé nous prévenir de
nouveaux actes terroristes alors cette
semaine le conseil d'état a refusé votre
demande la demande de la ligue des
droits de l'homme
des droits de l'homme parlant de
suspendre l'état d'urgence que vous lui
demandiez pour rappel les libertés
d'urgence doit prendre fin le 26 février
le gouvernement veut encore le prolonger
à une deuxième fois pour trois mois
elle vous êtes déçus que le conseil
d'état cette année n'est pas suspendu
cet état d'urgence
les amants bon c'est pas c'est pas une
totale surprise
non je crois surtout ce qu'il faudrait
pas ce qu'ils font il ya beaucoup de
fantasmes dessus et qu'il ya souvent une
confusion dans le public entre les
mesures indispensables d'exception et de
protections face en danger et l'état
d'urgence au sens légal du terme parce
qu'il faut rappeler on en est deux on
fait le calcul depuis 86 à la 10eme loi
antiterroriste mais ça c'est très
français d'ailleurs chaque fois qu'un
drame dans l'urgence eu le coup de
l'émotion on fait une loi ce qu'ils ont
fournie c'est très bien et a trait aux
crimes suivants on dit là bas lance la
serviette en faire une nouvelle fois
rien ce sera quand même et nous ce qui
nous quand même frappe c'est qu'on voit
pas autant c'est évident qu'il fallait
probablement même qu'à l'état d'urgence
se sont évidemment qu'il faut ce sont
des mesures d'exception face à des
crimes exceptionnel dans exceptionnel
mais faut-il pour autant et c'est 200 la
question faut-il pour autant faire un
certain nombre de restrictions aux
libertés dont personne n'a montré
qu'elle empêchait de lutter contre le
terrorisme
je suis désolé quand on dit il faut
assigne à résidence des militants
écologistes qui peut-être avait fait des
bêtises je n'en sais rien et c'est pas
la question
les moyens légaux s'ils avaient commis
des délits y l'église c'est plutôt
exempt des comices je me garderai bien
de le lire mais voulait dire qu'on
profite de l'état d'urgence
les outils existent jusqu'à maintenant
chaque fois que des crimes ont pu être
évité ça parle c'est pas les mesures
d'état d'urgence qui ont fait il exister
autrement et on ne va pas mon truc c'est
que ce que sahil par contre on a deux
dans un certain nombre de mesures
restrictives de liberté dont on trouve
absolument pas le rapport avec le
terrorisme à roye les détails frédéric
perrière est-ce que cet état d'urgence
depuis qu'il est mise hors notes c'est à
dire dès le lendemain
des attentats si je ne m'abuse très très
très peu de temps après est ce qu'il
vous a permis de travailler mieux
la question fondamentale finalement donc
là l'efficacité des efficacités des
perquisitions administrative a quand
même été démontrée puisque de l'argent
liquide dans certains endroits des armes
et ont malheureusement des produits
stupéfiants ont été découverts en
quantité assez importante sur le fond ça
permet aux collègues qui sont saisis
d'une situation de potentiel
radicalisation ou éventuellement d'une
d'une possible commission d'un acte
terroriste d'intervenir rapidement on
n'est pas obligé d'être dans le cadre de
la loi qui dit entre 21h et 6h les
perquisitions sont impossibles les
interventions sont impossibles je
rappellerai quand même que les derniers
faits se sont déroulés un peu en dehors
des heures légales puisque il était 22
heures à paris nous qu'on était vraiment
en dehors du temps légal pour que
l'action de la justice telle qu'elle
existe actuellement puisse fonctionner
par contre sur l'état d'urgence la
prolongation de l'état d'urgence à mon
avis de trois mois risquent en plus
quelque part d'être peut-être prolonger
un peu plus il faut qu'on s'habitue à
vivre avec ça puisque je rappellerai
pour les forces de sécurité on a une
échéance qui va se dérouler en france du
20 juin au 20 juillet qui est la coupe
d'europe de football
quand on voit l'objectif qui était
affichée par les terroristes la dernière
fois et qu'on sait qu'on va avoir des
matches sur tout le territoire français
on peut s'inquiéter et ça quelque part
derrière aussi pour nous forces de
sécurité c'est un problème qui est
vraiment particulier puisque nos
collègues sont vraiment au bout de ce
qu'on est capable de faire
karzaï alors l'état d'urgence bien sûr
il a été décrétée au lendemain et le
fallait et il le fallait je connais pas
un français qui est et qui aurait refusé
cette situation d'autant plus qu'on a vu
qu'on avait des terroristes qui n'était
qui était encore de la nature donc
c'était nécessaire maintenant ça dure
depuis quand même un moment est
d'ailleurs l'actuel ministre monsieur
irvoas à après avoir analysé parce que
on a des dés des points seront fed et
des bilans qui sont faits et lui même a
dit que l'état d'urgence s'essouffler
alors c'est vrai qu'il a permis à la
police de de faire un certain nombre
d'actions pour aller plus rapide et il a
beaucoup servi effectivement a retrouvé
des armes
pas forcément en lien avec avec le
terrorisme et on aurait pu
potentiellement le penser le penser mais
ça ça mais le point le doigt sur un
point c'est que 1
on n'avait pas suffisamment de moyens
policiers 2
c'est que le yassa à poser le problème
du renseignement aussi et ça ce sont des
vrais sujets sur lesquels il va falloir
blanche et le temps passé jean baptiste
alors bon je crois qu'effectivement on
fait face à un contexte qui
malheureusement va durer plusieurs
années
j'ai eu l'occasion d'échanger avec
xavier raufer un criminologue récemment
enfin pardon quand ils vous racontent ce
qui se prépare rien rapport d'europol
qui est paru il ya quelques jours
kiki vraiment voilà très inquiétant et
donc on doit nous adapter à cette donne
adopter un arsenal législatif et dans
cette attente effectivement l'état
d'urgence se justifie vous savez je suis
maire de vallery une petite commune du
gâtinais g à vallery deux rescapés du
bataclan je peux vous dire que quand
vous parlez avec eux songent dire sont
des héros parce qu'ils m'ont expliqué
comment ils ont ainsi créé 25 personnes
aura coûté cher à l'hectare xterra et
bien vous dit que dans ces cas là y'a
pas à tortiller il faut qu'on ait
l'arsenal est temporairement ça passe
par ça et dont on va parler de cet
arsenal dans quelques minutes mais il va
être mise
dans une poignée de secondes vous
propose de prendre connaissance de
l'actualité de ce samedi midi